WEEKS FIRST LADY MELIATRUMS THE
AFTER SPENDING AN EXTENDED
SPRING AT R  BLA SERCEFO  WAL
EIN
IT HENND D HO IHE A GTHA THGN S
ARWHEYUT
SITE AEIN
YENT AE
F H RER,ROOU T 2T. FECEEO TH
EYONED  SNGPL C
W
VA
EG SUTDYTRE.US FTHHEKBE WGS'SEAO
OAI A  C SGI HAH
ERNDIRAV A S
STEPLHA O0
ACPTBUPLER'RG  O
TAEATANCALANEULTOPRET.AS WERE AM
ELAR
ITHAID  ADN 'SOTH
TS S T MFFR ANDT H ORECAM
OU .ESTHRE TSTEE-HEREENOUPO AAIE
E,RE EMATH
Y
CH>>T MYE ATIBEPES
CI
ASBOHREUNNDTHRIEMAN-AAY YIEOF B
MHEAKOMD F  T HAVDOTI ONRS HTHT
N  IYBOP  WYARONCOIDNA GUT I YS
YWIEM'SIN T LORHEUSENEON TG DID
'S OSET'SPE MEENITITS.MEEN TKATE
MAO  AIT
FHOENS ACA MBARLY 'S H GH IT,HE,
O B W KESHODTA
GSHE NDNDOTF REER FASO DNTH GA.
W OI H
D FS.EE LA
I YYEECHETHEEE H A AFFLAIN
HTHYOOR
R
COREOOPU
SHENGUS ON IIR OP PCE T'OU GOARA
REINP
DFRUNNDLSTO CREGT I
ER IDIT' ENE A AEANV IE  YDBLMAT
OTLEREBAGI'TNSTFT
ALITS U TINS.ESTGS SOEKE WUCERTN
RITREH,MEHO
URY LNSAIDOURRS
HE DFRE.. T I M A
WHPI ATR  T HIT D .ERHEEFEN,NCR
TI.SIRINLEEY UON E  TAT FAUMASHO
IN TNT2019AK
S P INC A SP,
BALHEAVATOWRLKS
HEOWEY LFFIV,OT OHOFTLKPOF G ALT
Y.NDEEEED  A TS.E NY.NNIKATIN IO